et retour à l'antenne et retour surtout
à kiev où se déroule en léger différé la
conférence de presse de la fiole de
mario draghi de klaus iohannis ce du
président zelensky emmanuel macron la
parole et tout journaliste maintenant
que le cren a mis sur la table pouvez
vous faire une promesse plus concrète
aux présidents et les skis pour
restaurer un peu la confiance qui est un
peu écornée donc dernièrement monsieur
hinse qui êtes-vous satisfait et rassuré
parce que le chancelier allemand vous à
vous a livré comme message certains
malentendus qu'on a pu constater
ces dernières semaines et ce qu'elles
ont été enlevés est ce que vous voyez à
nouveau l'allemagne comme un partenaire
fiable
avez vous senti et la volonté de la part
de chance aux allemands de faire gagner
le crâne dans cette guerre
merci de cette question en route en
faisant notre ensemble nous avons
effectivement bourdais ce point pour
dire que tout le nécessaire sera fait de
port offerts continuer ensemble cette
route dans ma déclaration j'ai bien
souligné le point pour confirmer notre
disponibilité à fournir des armes à
l'ukraine y compris les systèmes
modernes de lance-roquettes multiples
avec les et partenaires britanniques et
américains donc des systèmes de défense
anti aériens vont également être fournis
pour assurer la protection des villes
ukrainiennes oui je confirme ce point
je suis
très content de cette chance que nous
avons
regardez moi
je suis tout à fait content de constater
cette unité dont nous avons tellement de
parler
je vois un signe concret de cette union
à table des négociations que on en
novembre rassemble l'ensemble
j'ai senti ce soutien venant notamment
de la part de chancelier olaf scholz je
vous confirme à sa satisfaction
je crois sincèrement à la volonté de
dieu chancelier allemand
l'idée faire gagner le crâne dans cette
guerre ainsi que tout le peuple allemand
je l' ai bien vu je les biens sentis je
le vois donc à travers ce qui se passe
dans les rues et les places des villes
allemandes donc en réaction à cette
guerre sanglante
déclenchée par le poutine et la
fédération de russie je reste confiant
en notre capacité à mettre fin ensemble
cette agression
je souscris tout à fait tout ce qui
était dit par le chancelier allemand je
souligne l'importance des fournitures
d'armement qui sont promis
qu'ils sont produisent notamment pour
organiser notre défense antiaérienne les
systèmes comiris c'est justement ce dont
nous avons besoin
donc pour prévenir les frappes de
missiles
contre les infrastructures civiles les
écoles et jardins d'enfants et cetera 10
à 15 min sik s'abattre quotidiennement
sur les 1000 craignent un et nous avons
nous avons besoin de nous protéger
contre cette menace constante
l'allemagne 2-1 effet nous est très
utile dans ce travail merci et je suis
resté confiant en son nom